o urso ao bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma mini
pistola usando pulinhos de picolé que
vocês podem contar a venda nas
procuradorias vocês quiserem podem
comprar cinco seis lados também vão
conseguir fazer esta supere permeia por
tentar mas é não tanto tempo mas tenta o
cinto vocês não apontarem contra ninguém
e usar óculos de proteção
está aqui o template deixo o linck na
instituição é só carregar no link
confira imagem e carregarem prime que
vai estar tudo a um dia eo resto é
bastante simples é só ir que passa
páginas de imagens e acho que nem vale a
pena falar se eu começar a falar você
muita besteira e yero 22 mão de tudo nos
comentários
e isso só faça tudo com cuidado e
práticas que se usava proteção
[Música]
eu
sim a frontal chegamos ao fim e esperta
no estado
vocês gostaram mesmo deixem voz só eu
posso cobrir e se inscreva no canal que
estuda bastante divulgação e evolução do
meu trabalho e claro que tiverem mais
sugestões do projeto
deixe nos comentários que como vocês
podem ver que eu faço é isso e pronto
um grande abraço e até a frança em tempo
real e agora tem uma pistola